enrico campari in china car in the wall
of china zu kommen zu einem neuen video
heute die bedeute wird kein gewöhnliches
video seien heute werden wir nach
forscher interessiert nun zu euch fragen
sie jetzt wonach werden heute forschen
was wird der gegenstand des heutigen
video sein herz dem titel schon gesehen
leute wir werden heute detektivisch
vorgehen die videos mit den meisten
dislike auf youtube aufspüren und wir
werden versuchen zu verstehen dass du
gehst du bist auch wikipedia sei die
liste mit den 40 meist gibt es live
videos aller zeiten wenn ich dann
gedacht hat was die und eine
beschreibung auf euch wie ihr fit muss
erstmal ein paar highlights raus und
fangen direkt an
man muss ganz ehrlich sagen heute den
anfang kennt man überhaupt nicht warten
tv portals fundus an der gehört welches
tutorials sind solche gesichter aber die
alle haben sich von einem mann
überbieten haften von diesen mann finden
wir auf platz 20 der nike dürften video
aller zeiten weltweit und ist kein
geringerer als mister fragen wer es
nicht geschafft auf fi data der sage und
schreibe 8 186 tausende damit weltweit
auf platz 20 somit den großen bekannten
spiel deswegen springen jetzt noch
vorletzte woche der platzierung der auf
platz 13 den pokémon grosjean von mythos
die der hat sage und schreibe 11 66
millionen discs gesammelt bei 63 prozent
ist eine gesamten bewertungen
[Musik]
diese liste kann sowas ganz so ernst
dass ge wenige fonds in meinem leben die
ich mehr feiere alte wird jeder der mich
kennt sollte mir vorbeikommen eine wir
kehren das mann gegen mann man kann so
wie dieses zweiten das war platz 13 auf
der liste der meisten videos aller
zeiten und auf platz zwölf haben den
video was sicher einige von euch kennen
werden und zwar mehr berisha muss ich
das sagt jeder von euch gern zu
schreiten
[Musik]
was zur hölle ist das 1 2 milliarden
aufrufe
ich hab mich wirklich hoch nehmen also
zwei milliarden aufrufe büros gibt auch
der restwelt vielleicht 5000 leute bevor
immer völlig ausrastet ich weiß es gibt
mehr als 2000 russen ich kann damit
nichts anfangen ist denn diese
zeichentrickserie von mama mama und papa
alles klar gibt es ein paar musikvideos
ihm eigentlich kennt weekend dafür ist
ein konter von nicki minaj wrecking ball
von miley cyrus und sechs tutorials teil
alter auffordert eigentlich okay
gangster 12 868 milliarden auf jetzt
stellt euch mal vor gang starr so der
bund über den alle geräte müssten auf
youtube rauf und runter eigentlich jeder
kennen gang amtszeit und dann gibt es
ein video von mama und papa vor dem
scheiß berdych gegen tanzt und es hat
auch einfach über zwei milliarden auf
fast für die games teil dafür bist du
eine erklärung wird und zwar in jedem
land der welt man nur entfernt gespräch
hat jeder einzelne bürger dieses video
von mama und papa ich weiß nicht was
ausspreche gesehen jeder einzelne punkt
gewinnen die letzte russische um einem
dorf in sibirien merklich nachließen
vater hat verkaufte sehen wir haben
jetzt gesehen hatten einige musikvideos
aber dazu kam es nicht viel sagen sollte
aber geschmackssache ob man sweatshirt
von jacob tutorials mag manche hafens
manche fans richtig scheiße und dann
haben wir auch klartext wieder ein
klassiker die nach bestimmt jeder von
euch kennen und war nicht geringeres als
kommando rot oder youtube muss ich dazu
noch irgendwas sagen wirklich zu
kommando ist hause youtube noch
irgendwann ich meinen jeder von uns hat
das gesehen leute warum ein video das in
meiner oma das gerät ist es doch foto
die sich schon wieder herscheid wieviel
portugiesisch sprechenden menschen gibt
auf der welt kennen sie findet es lustig
das video hat nur 24 millionen nur dass
wir jungen mann ganzes leben auf rufe
aber auch 24 millionen aufrufe 23 36
millionen discs heißt fast jeder zehnte
der das video gesehen hat hat
gelassen verstimmung das video ist 32
machten noch in gold auf ihre free to
play button
ich verstehe aber trotzdem nicht
brasilianer oder portugiesin der play
button durchschneidet es ist freilich
nur noch in nur 100 k play button
ok-chef 150 millionen keine ahnung voll
vergolder lamborghini r8 hätte ein
fucking silberner privaten leute ich
kann nicht wirklich verstehen aber wir
können was machen wir können daran
arbeiten dass diese menschliche von
headup bekommt und es geht ganz einfach
jeder von euch kann das machen die mir
einfach das video geht und das lag
dallas teile auf platz fünf in der liste
haben wir niemand geringeren als bianca
heinicke eigentlich um dem winter ganz
folgen müssen wir hier das video
anschauen
das erspart ihnen jetzt markt darüber
haben wir noch auf platz vier freie von
rebecca black music endet video games
live community was drei millionen hat
also für die premiere des livestreams
recorder video und dann wird richtig
spannend denn auch platz zwei haben wir
den call of duty infinity ward reveal
trailer und dann leute auf platz 1 der
absolut ungekrönte könig aller zeiten
mit dem video mit 7,8 millionen desktops
mehr als doppelt so viel wie der zweite
platz wie der küste wird irgendwann zu
sagen ich glaube das war wirklich jeder
von euch die story macher und cover das
ist dürfen die meisten von euch bekannt
sein baby mit 7,8 millionen displays sat
1 und damit auch unser ausflug in die
meisten videos aller zeiten heute wenn
jetzt die im kopf hat das noch mehr
displays haben soll das ist jetzt hat
dann statt wenn die kommentare per cool
wenn ich meine videos rein schreibt die
unpersönliche
vorgeschlagen das video in kalabrien und
hier oben komplett zur neuesten folge
was geht von meinem format mit
unitymedia trifft gerne mal ab und
lassen viel leichter und auch kein kabel
rausreißen 25